I don't know why it took me 30 years to  discover these they're called crocodile  or joined eclipse and they have this  cool mechanism that expands to grab a  big chunk of hair or whatever else you  need to grab I don't know your life I  have a lot of heavy hair so I've just  had Decades of weak little Clips  struggling to hold onto my hair and  maybe I just didn't love myself enough  to look for a solution I used them in  the shower on wet and on dry hair  treatments for dyeing my hair clipping  up my hair when it's really hot and I  don't have to leave the house so no one  has to see my great style I use one for  clipping a towel around my partner's  shoulders when I did his quarantine  haircuts this is a highly recommended  quality of life upgrade treat yourself  to a one dollar clip